welcome back lot of media organizations
from Channel 4 to the BBC and the
guardian are facing tough questions of
the Apparently Open Secret of Russell
Bran's Behavior but the spotlight has
also been turned on journalists who
reported the claims against him br's
Defenders asked why now why didn't they
go to police and legal experts have
warned he have no Prospect of a fair
trial given all this open speculation
joining me now to discuss this is the
broadcast inform Su times Andrew Neil
Andrew great to have you on PE Morgan
censor thank you for coming on um can't
think of anyone better placed than you a
former editor of Sunday Times let me
start with their investigation when you
read it what was your verdict
professionally as a piece of
investigative journalism when I read it
and finished it I was very proud of the
Sunday Times it was exactly in the
tradition of that
newspapers uh history of investigative
journalism when I took over his editor
that tradition had died a little bit I
did my best when I was there to put
investigative journalism back into the
center of it we got a lot of great
invest invative Stories the famous
Insight team probably the most famous
investigative unit in the world had new
life in it and that is continued you
know people often say oh investigative
journalism is dead well this shows that
it isn't it was meticulous it was
unhurried that you go four years
investigative journalism is expensive
and not quick you got to get things
right you got to get a lawyer sometimes
the life of his lawyer out of it and of
course they gave Mr brand eight days to
resp respond and you and I know as ex
editors peers they given the the ability
in Britain to get gagging injunctions um
to stop publication of stories that was
quite a dangerous thing to do so I think
they did everything the right way they
presented it correctly uh they got the
research done correctly they laid it out
and let's see where it goes from here
yeah and I think that's the crucial bit
for me is that lots of people jumping on
uh various bandwagons here many racing
to say well he's obviously guilty that's
it he must be cancelled forever from
everything which is already happening
corporately others going the other way
saying no it's all a conspiracy by
mainstream media which of course is I
think a lot of nonsense I'm sure you
share that view I've seen your tweets
about that so what we're left with is
where this will go legally and there is
a concern by the legal world that this
may already actually no longer be able
to go to a courtroom because of all the
prejudicial materials been out there
what do you say to that uh it's the
usual self pleading of lawyers um who
don't like journalists but they don't
like us as much as we don't like
lawyers and uh you know if you follow
this line then we do nothing we do no
serious journalism at all oh we can't
publish this it might affect a fair
trial somewhere at some unspecified
period down the pike and I would just
point out if it wasn't for the Sunday
Times Channel 4 investigation you and I
wouldn't be talking about the
possibility of criminal proceedings in
the first place been plenty of time to
get to that it's only only because of
this investigative journalism that
there's even now the possibility we
don't know whether it'll happen or not
at least the possibility of investig of
of criminal proceedings taking place
that wouldn't have happened without this
investigation so I really think that is
is a way of trying to stop journalists
doing their proper job we need more of
this not less yeah and actually I was
reminding people yesterday the Harvey
Weinstein Scandal was broken by
journalists women going to journalists
who then published the revelations that
led to a police invest instigation and
now he's languishing in prison probably
the rest of his life but that started
the same way and I think for the women
involved this is very important too we
know how difficult it is for women to
come forward in these circumstances we
know the pressures not to do are huge
and it could be in in this case as in
the Weinstein case that women speaking
to journalists to newspapers first is an
interim stage before it then results in
wider proceedings and facilitates
their ability to do so and I think
that's another plus too but there is you
know there's a Bedrock of a of a
Democratic Society which is innocent
till proven guilty and that's not proven
guilty by a newspaper or by social media
ultimately it has to be be proven in a
court of law and I have a view about
this that whatever you think of Russell
Brand and you can make your own mind up
about his morals from everything he said
himself Mariel read out some pretty
disturbing stuff early from his own book
his own words I read some from an
interview I did with him for GQ which
now looks pretty unsavory but but he
remains at the moment somebody who
should be considered innocent till
proven guilty by the law shouldn't he
yes and that's our way of doing things
but it you know the newspaper is not or
Channel 4 they're not trying and
convicting him that's not their job
their job is to put information don't
forget the best definition of Journalism
is to put into the public domain facts
that powerful people don't want to see
in the public domain and this is a
classic example of that this isn't trial
by media uh the newspaper and the
television station have done their job
it is now if this is going to be a trial
that's a job for the police yeah that's
a job for the prosecution service that's
a job for the courts not a job for the
newspapers to do that their job is to
expose and reveal that's what theyve
done whether we go forward into that
into criminal matters is um another
matter entirely and not for the media to
decide but I think the one thing that we
do already know is whether criminality
is involved or not which as I say is not
for mere journalist that decide it's
pretty clear there was some egregious
Behavior going on here some behavior
that anybody should be ashamed of and
that major media companies were
complicit and I think we're seeing a lot
of hypocrisy now because I see all these
people now rushing to disassociate
themselves from Russell Brown well I
would ask a fundamental question
question why were they ever associated
with him in the first place for me some
of the most revealing footage in the
documentary was not the investigative
journalism strong as it was it was his
performances as a so-called standup
comedian in which he was neither funny
but consistently vulgar root and
unwatchable why did the BBC why did
Channel 4 why did the guardian why did
the new Statesman why did the labor
party ever wanted to be associated with
essentially this SAS bag in the first
place you know you know I mean I think
to play Devil's Advocate the answer I
would imagine is that although you found
him grotesque and unfunny clearly a lot
of people found him hilarious they just
did you know he he sold buckets of books
he put loads of ratings onto television
programs he wrote columns that were
widely disseminated and enjoyed so he's
one of those very polarizing figures and
he does have Ian he's got six and a half
million people subscribed to his YouTube
channel there's a huge following there
and I'm sure that if you and I put
public hands on our program be pretty
good for ratings for a while as well you
know there are some things as standards
and and you know particularly in Britain
where there's a strong tradition of
Public Service broadcasting and not just
doing it for the money not just doing it
because it's commercial because it gets
big ratings it was two Public Service
broadcasters the vbc and channel 4 which
facilitated this guy to do it and they
shouldn't have done and you know we have
an ability in our culture I think it's
true in America parts of Europe but
above all in Britain where we Elevate
people of no Talent people of no
redeeming value whatsoever to the status
of national icons I give you Jimmy sad
it's a classic example of that a man of
not Talent who had a hot line to
Margaret Thatcher and the royal family
and in a different way I'm not comparing
the two in terms of what they did in a
different way we elevated Russell bran
to be this man that seem to have the
pulse of young people in British Society
whose every word we should hang on and
was worthy of interviews on the BBC's
news night or Guardian conferences or
editing the news Statesman is just
nonsense and this power of celebrity
which seems to have the ability to make
sensible people stupid this is another
another classic example of it and it is
corrosive of our culture and what is
good in it Andre Neil I think in cricket
parlance you've just come off the long
run and I appreciate you joining the
program see behind me there's a good
cricket match going on here that's the
year England won the ashes fantastic
well then it's an appropriate analogy
Andrew great to talk to you thank you
thank you
peers